back here at home losing a loved one to
covet is never easy and fema's funeral
assistance is meant to ease financial
burden on families but as mary jane
bellieso shares some people may not know
they qualify for these benefits
when patrick cassell lost his mother to
covid in december 2020. he applied for
fema's funeral assistance program but
had a tough time completing the
application sometimes the paperwork is a
little more tedious and if we can get
help from a funeral home that would be
awesome because we all need help when it
comes to filling out government
paperwork that's the key fema's funeral
assistance provides up to nine thousand
dollars in burial cremation and eligible
services to qualified families who lost
a loved one due to covet 19. laura
sussman is a funeral director at kraft
sussman funeral and cremation services
she says filling out paperwork can be
intimidating for those already dealing
with grief and most people are shocked
they didn't know that it was available
or the government was doing that for
them but this doesn't have to be done
right away
so people could take their time they
have to wait until they get the death
certificate you know wait until all of
their funeral expenses are incurred
because
like some people at the beginning of
covet couldn't even do a service they
you know they were postponing that
so if they file you only get one chance
to file so if they file before they have
all their costs involved they're not
going to get reimbursed for the
additional costs casale hopes to provide
a bigger and proper service for his
mother in the future after covet limited
gatherings he says in the meantime he's
going to try applying again you know
when you're dealing with somebody's
death i mean we would have talked a year
ago or maybe 15 months ago i don't know
how or not 12 months ago yeah about a
year ago i don't know how receptive i
would be now a year later
um things are more digested and you know
you live with it now is a good time to
probably want to apply mary jane bella
live local now
well to apply for this relief you will
need proof of funeral expenses an
official death certificate listing covet
19 as the cause of death and you must
disclose any funds received specifically
for funeral costs and will offset the
fema benefits